35 الف سجاده خضراء تغطي مصليات مساحات
الحرم المكي بطول اجمالي يلامس مئاتكم
كالقى عنايه خاصه من قبل رئاسه الشؤون
الحرمين المختصه باعمال الصيانه والنظافه
والتعقيم باجود انواع المواد الصديقه
للبيئه والاجهزه الحديثه
[موسيقى]
تجري عمليات تنظيف يوميه للسجاد عبر خمس
مراحل داخل مغسله ضخمه تابعه لاداره
التطهير والفرش بمكه المكرمه على ايدي
مختصين يتم غسيل السجاد عن الطريقه خمسه
مراحل المرحله الاولى هي مرحله ازاله
الغبار والنمس والاتربه حاليا في المرحله
الثانيه يكون غسل السجاد عن طريق الشامبو
والمعقم
بازاله الشامبو عن طريق الماء الصافي في
المرحله الثالثه يتم تجفيف السجاد عن طريق
عصره داخل انبوب في المرحله الرابعه يتم
نشر السجاد تحت اشعه الشمس والهواء النقي
حتى يتم التاكد من تجفيفه بعد ذلك المرحله
الاخيره هي المرحله الخامسه هي كنز السجاد
وتعطيره بالمعطل الورد تبلغ الطاقه
الانتاجيه اليوميه لغسيل السجاد
240 مترا في الساعه الواحده وتعمل على
مدار الساعه لتزويد المسجد الحرام بشكل
يومي بالسجاد بعدها تشغيل الحرم المكي
بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه هذا العام من
مكه المكرمه سلطان السلمي العربيه